cuba comienza la vacunación masiva y lo
hace con dos vacunas desarrolladas en la
isla
abdalá y soberana dos que requieren tres
dosis aunque abdalá acaba de terminar su
tercera fase de ensayos y soberana 2 lo
hará a mediados de mayo es una noticia
esperada por muchos cubanos que
enfrentan el azote del virus
es que yo creo que el cubo entera está
esperando la vacuna yo creo que sí yo
creo que sí y tengo mucho
ellos tienen fe en la vacuna y yo
particularmente tengo una funda
confianza en mente en ella yo la estoy
esperando con los brazos abiertos sin
embargo la inoculación empezará sin la
aprobación de emergencia del centro para
el control estatal de medicamentos
el organismo regulador cubano que se
espera la otorgue en junio el gobierno
cree que los beneficios son superiores a
los riesgos desde el ministerio de salud
se estimó que para agosto un 70 por
ciento de la población está inmunizada
pero nosotros pensamos que ya en el mes
de junio tengamos inmunizar 22 6% de la
población
en julio 30 y 35 y en agosto el 70 por
ciento de esa población la vacunación
comienza con 500.000 trabajadores
sanitarios excluye a menores de edad y
es voluntaria o es el único país de
latinoamérica que ha desarrollado cinco
vacunas propias no obstante hace unos
meses está viviendo un repunte de casos
con más de mil nuevos positivos por
quinto día consecutivo